mal
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt wer mir auf facebook oder auf
instagram folgt weiß vielleicht dass ich
ein paar tage in frankreich bin und zwar
bin ich jetzt gerade in den bug schießen
ich bin ja sehr oft immer auf messen
unterwegs und hab letztes jahr auf der
ambiente müsse eine firma kennen gelernt
und zwar die firma db und die sind aus
frankreich und stellen auch ihre
produkte in frankreich her und ich finde
es immer wieder schön wenn ich euch
einfach mal zeigen kann wo die produkte
hergestellt werden wer hinter der firma
steckt und für mich ist natürlich auch
immer sehr interessant wer sind die
menschen die hier arbeiten
wie ist die firmenphilosophie und was
wird wirklich vor ort hergestellt mir
ist es ja immer ganz wichtig dass ich
meine produkte entweder direkt aus
deutschland oder aus europa bekommen
einfach weil bei uns eben die
arbeitsbedingungen stimmen es gibt faire
löhne und ich möchte natürlich auch
wissen wo kommen die rohstoffe her und
ich fand es jetzt ganz schön dass jetzt
nach frankreich reisen durfte zur firma
db habe hier die produkte gesehen habe
fiel in der produktion auch gesehen
ich weiß jetzt zum beispiel wie man
gewisse produkte herstellt und habe
natürlich auch die menschen hier
kennengelernt
heute bin ich mit der serie hier und wir
haben jetzt auch die letzte zeit
zusammen ein paar französische
spezialitäten gemacht und werden auch
heute hier in der versuchsküche ein paar
spezialitäten zubereiten und ich werde
euch einfach so ein bisschen was über
die firma erzählen über die produkte und
natürlich auch in einblick geben in die
produktion
und wir haben jetzt hier ein bisschen
was vorbereitet wir werden jetzt eine
crêpe torte machen mit lemon gehört und
wer sie also mehr ringe genau ich würde
sagen wir starten einfach mal direkt mit
dem crap teig und machen das einfach zu
sehen gut also an zutaten haben wir hier
vorne mehl zucker etwas milch wir haben
flüssige butter meine vanille extrakte
muster natürlich mit ich hab's mit
eingepackt ich habe eier und saales im
crap teig ist es ja nicht wichtig dass
der luft rein kommt deswegen römer das
ist auch nur mit so einem flachen gags
aber so dass wir jetzt einfach schön
verrührt vanille und so weiter salz das
nicht vergessen
ja natürlich
natürlich den crap auch so ein süßes
aber die prise salz dürfte auch nicht
vergessen die haben mir schon drin dann
etwas vanille extrakt und dann ist der
teig im prinzip auch schon fertig und
wir können ihn erst mal stehen lassen
will der muss ein bisschen quellen und
in der zwischenzeit richten wir schon
mal die zutaten für das level curt fürs
leben könnten wir jetzt schon die
zutaten gerichtet lemon gehört ist er
seine zitronencreme die mit stärke und
mit eingebunden wird deswegen haben wir
hier ganz viel zitronensaft hier haben
wir zitronenschale von bio zitrone eier
zucker und stärke und später kommt noch
butter mit rein
jetzt geben wir auch direkt die
zitronenschale mit rein und wir kochen
das jetzt in so einem kupfer topf und er
sind kupfer dorf habe ich auch zu hause
also vielleicht habt ihr auch schon mal
gesehen diese kupfer kasserolle und ich
konnte mir am anfang juni vorstellen wie
so ein top hergestellt wird und zwar in
der produktion zeigt euch mal ein paar
ausschnitte denn so einer top hab ich
selber hergestellt
hier zeigt nicht mal wie aus dieser
platte in hochwertiger coop entsteht
und zwar habe ich die scheibe schon
eingesetzt
es muss einfach nur noch kontrollieren
ob er eben auch schön gerade gewonnen
wir zeigen es
warum ist die qualität kommt wird
die an der station werden jetzt töpfen
und pfannen verpackt und zwar werden die
vorher erst mal poliert das heißt man
bekommt da eben alle flecken wächst es
ja auch hochwertiges produkt man möchte
das produkt natürlich auch perfekt beim
kunden ankommt nach dem polieren wird
dann hier verpackt geht hier zur
mitarbeiterin röber und sie packt alles
schön in einem karton ein
und dann kommen die kartons einfach so
beim kunden an
in der zwischenzeit dürfte das leveln
karte zum fest werden und damit wir
keine klümpchen drin haben passieren wir
das einmal hier durch und lassen es dann
etwa zehn minuten abkühlen und geben
dann erst die butter mit dazu dazu gehen
ort ist dass du machen und im rat
schmuggelt sich wie immer einfach durchs
bild
der schlechte immer herum
crêpes ganz dünne
ja das ist ja ganz dünn
tostedt kalt werden
gibt es hier die crêpes mit einem back
rahmen zurechtschneiden damit wir
einfach später eine schöne runde torte
zu bereiten und dekorieren können
größe immer ganz gerne back rahmen zum
backen und habe mich natürlich gefragt
wie stellt man von einem bakken
überhaupt her als zeig ich euch jetzt
mal wie man die in der fabrik herstellt
ich habe zwar hier zu den runden aber
ich zeige euch wie man einen echten
bagger
also hier steht jetzt ganz am anfang der
produktion gibt es auch ziemlich laut
und zwar nennen wir die rohstoffe
verarbeitet er mit dem rohstoff
edelstahl und je nachdem was man hat er
jedenfalls oder andere rohstoffe kommen
sie immer und verschiedenen länder
parteien wieder auf fragen direkt oder
aus europa mit hier auch eine rolle
angelegt hat und zwar auch beim
transport heben den platz zu sparen
damit dann aber der rohstoff wieder
gerade wird kommt es ihr euch denn alles
rund läuft hier entlang
und wärst hier in form gestanden hatte
aus diesem langen strang werden musste
strittiges sowie hier und die werden
dann auch direkt hier oben abgerundet
sie hören auf die scharfe kante und hier
oben abgerundet
aber wieder vorn dabei
alles ist allerdings umstritten
der rat muss ich mal
mit den teil den wir weiter zur nächsten
station
an sechs stationen werden jetzt hier die
scharfen kanten abgeschliffen alles
heran und war deswegen damit man sich
einfach nicht mehr drum verletzen kann
und auch hier wird eine tochter achtet
dass immer noch diese schutzfolie drauf
ist und dass die form eben nicht sagt
kraft wird wenn ich jetzt hier das
ungestörte nehmen und den fingern
überstreichen höhere können sich daran
verletzen aber jetzt beim geschliffenen
oder gar nicht mehr
was ich hier ganz toll finde dass die
fabrik lesern in firmen können auch
herkommen at firmenpartner können sich
die fabrik anschauen können ganzen
produktionsprozess von anfang bis zum
ende anschauen und eben auch fragen
stellen und das system super aber da
wird es für alle systeme weiter
hier an der station werden jetzt hier
diese scharfe kanten abgerundet
zwar geht es in dem man die ausstattung
und am ende haben wir dann alle seiten
schön abgerungen
an dieser station werden jetzt nicht nur
diese rundungen gestand sondern hier
werden auch die langen teile
aufgestanden und zwar hier das innere
damit man die formen gleich umknicken
kann es wieder ein eckiger programmen
wie man jetzt von dem teil zu dem teil
vom zeige ich euch an dieser maschine
diese teile die gefundenen teile müssen
gut verpackt werden
dafür laufen wir dann die nächste
station und zwar wird hier jetzt finde
ich die folie entfernt
das macht setzt das ganze dann kindchen
unersetzlich die teile zu einem bug
rahmen zusammen
anschließend kommt ein etikett mit drauf
und er legt dann auf dieses fließband
vorne wird verpackt ganz automatisch in
folie geschweißt und dann fällt sie nun
in die transportbox
und so schön verpackt wieder ist nämlich
die nicht und gehe mit dem in der küche
habe sein programm mitgebracht okay aber
den nehme ich mit nach hause unsere
torte ist jetzt auch fertig werden sie
noch einen kühlschrank
ich will zeigen wir probieren jetzt mal
aber wieso hast du dir eigentlich für
die krippe entschieden weil im februar
machen
crêpes fest das ist ja das heißt schon
und dann haben wir gesagt vielleicht
können wir ja zusammen machen also darum
haben wir das entscheiden
es wird auf jeden fall sehr lecker aus
mit den vielen einzelnen schichten so
schön
und die torte riecht auch sehr lecker
nicht immer die zitrone recht deutlich
becker ist die zitrone macht die torte
sehr fruchtigen und dem bc masse die
meringer masse gleich das ganze mit
ihrer flüsse noch mal aus wirklich sehr
gut
falls ihr gerne wissen möchte wie wird
die torte hergestellt haben kann ich
euch auch gerne das rezept noch mal zu
hause nachmachen dann schreibt man
einfach in die kommentare
ich fand's auf jeden fall ganz toll auch
noch mal in die produktion reinzuschauen
okay war wirklich super den bug rahmen
hier den nehme ich einfach mit makel zu
hause etwas damit und zeigt euch den
einfach mal daheim und wir lassen uns
jetzt ein kuchen schmecken geben noch
ein bisschen was in der fabrik abdi war
alles so fleißig und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal wieder distanzschuss
für den kompletten besucht dankeschön
für die gastfreundschaft